this podcast and every other podcast I
make is brought to you by my supporters
on patreon who got this podcast several
days early and also featuring several
extra minutes Extended Cut where Justin
and Alec were talking about what they
had for breakfast including Panda
Express somehow if you want to support
the show which I understand is pretty
Niche go to
patreon.comclick link in the description
also before we get into this episode I
did want to note that as also before we
go any further I did want to note that
for this particular episode the guest
requested it to not be on camera so I'm
just going to be showing some high on
life gameplay which I need to give
credit to the YouTube channel Gamers
little playground for I will link them
in the description also go ahead intro
intro the show
hey everybody Welcome to my show no I'm
just kidding that's pretty much it yeah
uh hello everyone welcome to another
episode of video game riding101 today I
am joined by Alec and Justin uh Alec who
are you what do you do
I'm the narrative director over at
squanch games uh this was the first game
I've worked at at squanch games so um
I'm super pumped sorry what's the name
of the game did a lot
oh the game it's called high on life
thank you for asking uh Justin how about
you I know Ian what are you doing here
um I am the CEO of squanch games and
um
I don't know I I kind of
uh
uh big picture big picture story big
story like big idea person yeah um
poking around uh like
you know working with amazing talented
people and and
and
being like fortunate enough to have them
believe in my weird crazy ideas and and
then add even cooler crazy ideas on top
of them and
make a big giant sandwich of amazing
cool crazy ideas but like
yeah just built the studio and and I had
I mean no clue that we would ever I just
had no idea that we would get to the
point where we are now which is really
kind of amazing but um and we and and
yeah I I don't know like like this the
way I run the studio is so different
than like maybe what people think a CEO
is you know it's it's it's a more
creative focused and
driving us more in like
um
you know just real big fun crazy ideas
and character unfortunately kind of
unusual for a CEO
well I I want to make I mean this whole
thing is built was built because I
wanted to make things that don't exist
uh that I really want to play myself
it's the same thing with like you know
linear content too there's like there's
like movie ideas and there's TV show
ideas and there's and there's plenty of
video games that don't yet
exist exactly the way I really want them
to or
oh man yeah so like I that that was how
the studio was born and then and then
we've kind of just followed that you
know and and what's exciting now is we
have an amazing team and there's other
people on the team that feel the same
way where they're like oh I really wish
this thing would exist and now and we're
we're hoping you know with if high on
life does well that we'll be able to
start you know servicing other folks on
the teams you know like dreams of like
oh my God I really want this to exist so
I can play it you know and that's kind
of like the sort of the Company motto
let's make stuff that we would really
really want to play and have fun playing
if we didn't like if you if you if you
could Eternal Sunshine of the Spotless
Mind me of this game I think I would
really [ __ ] love this game
yeah my my I think like what is my steam
hours it's at like 600 something hours
played I mean it's just like I I'm it's
I can't even I don't even know I'm like
I just don't know so I wasn't even
talking about game coverage mostly went
up this morning I'm catching you both a
few hours after that happened
um I think we already did chat about it
a little bit but but how are you feeling
now that you have seen people actually
play high on life
like it's had a lot of traction people
have had a lot of opinions it's been um
highly anticipated from the way I would
see it but did you guys expect it had a
lot of eyes on it yeah no I mean well
you with Trover it was like crickets you
know nobody knew we even put out a game
um but this one right from the get-go
it's yeah it's had a lot of eyes on it
uh hold on I think I'm getting a cold
I'm like me I'm gonna sneeze
oh god wow that's a lot of really good
snooze yeah sorry I don't normally I
oh my God I hate I hate loud sneezes and
I'm so sorry I had to subject you guys
to that okay leave that in do not cut
that sneeze
um but uh no like I I yeah it's it's
crazy you know
yeah it's just it's out there and it's
like I think a lot of Comedy games get
eyes on them because that's a kind of a
rarity
you know so much of Comedy is timing
right so how do you approach writing or
or United Direction in general for a
game like this where you don't actually
have all of the control of the timing
for comedy purposes like I imagine you
have to approach things very differently
than anything that's you know millennia
yeah this is a very long answer because
there's just a multitude of ways we've
approached it like even uh like the most
common way we do it is we kind of try to
anticipate something a player might try
and then have one of the characters
react to it and I feel like that's our
bread and butter like they're like that
was happening intro or even before I
joined um and like you would just kind
of sit there wondering what's a
controller can I do this and then you do
it and then a character is like hey you
can't do that or something
um that's an easy laugh I feel like
every time we do it it makes someone
smile but the other stuff like you know
fine-tuning the length of what we call
like Half-Life style cutscenes where
you're just kind of walking around just
characters talk making sure it's funny
on a on a linear like because those are
the more linear scenes in the game where
the player has less control like those
are just scripted that's that's just
gonna live or die by what's written but
the rest of it we try to make
interactive and give you fun little
things you can play with and uh I don't
know it's it's kind of like a toy when I
look at it sometimes like we give you
the tools and the verbs and then you
press them and they make a silly noise
and that should be fun
yeah I mean it's it's a it's a lot of I
mean there's so many different types of
um narrative design moments or just
narrative or just comedy moments in the
game
uh falling into all kinds of different
buckets and Alex sort of hit most of
them you know you'll have a player that
is
you'll walk up to an NPC and you're
they're they're they're interacting with
you and they're talking to you and as
you leave you might leave right before
the funniest part and but you know
they'll be like oh okay I guess all
right you're leaving okay see you later
you know we like we so we lean into it
like we have a bunch of jokes that we're
just we we collectively as a team
decided it's fine if the player misses
this we have things that are really
buried we have things that like I've
been watching some streams today and
there's a few jokes that everybody's
missed and I'm like you know what for
the three people that find that it's
gonna hit very hard it almost makes it
funnier because they've opted into it so
strongly right
oh yeah yeah opt-in opt-in um
interactions or like our favorite and
that's the thing that we try to like
like every scenario we have we try to
think how can we make this an opt-in
um versus like a lockdown
um you know this game this game being as
ambitious and and big and story heavy as
it is we did have to revert to a resort
to like a few lockdowns you know like
yeah there's some funnel points we just
got to get some Exposition across and
you got to stand there yeah
yeah and we thought a long a lot about
how can we do this so it is in a
lockdown but ultimately but but what we
did do is where we thought there were
um the need to lock down we we in a lot
of places we realized there weren't
there there wasn't so we were able to
you know do it do it the way we we we
really want to do it and
um and that opt-in kind of energy you
know like for players that that want to
hang out and I mean like okay for
a good example like really early in the
game
um Lizzy just you're you know she's on
your bed she's your sister uh
and you know she's getting high which is
the theme you know overarching theme of
this entire game
um drug use
uh and you know she's just got a lot of
[ __ ] she's dumping on you you can just
sit and listen to her and and that's um
Laura Silverman who's so [ __ ]
talented and great
and it's um
it's it's crazy you can sit and listen
and it's so funny the [ __ ] she's talking
about is so great I really regret that I
didn't
do that yeah
it's easy to skip it that's one of those
things you're talking about
yeah I mean you could you could select
your you could select your your
character and and and and and in all all
in like within five seconds and move
right past it but like if you wanted to
just you know sit and hang with her
she is telling you all kinds of gossip
about you know it's just great it's
really fun and how does that work for
scoping like I feel like this is such a
big thing in game development is like
how you you Scope or budget for the
amount of things that you can fit into a
game that in a lot of cases if players
won't see them like how often were you
having conversations about the scope of
the game and what needs to get cut or
are you just you just going all out not
cutting anything
I ended up holding back more than I
needed to sometimes like as the writer
like there were plenty of moments where
I just assumed it would be too
complicated to do a certain way or then
someone would be like hey actually uh
it's totally fine if you had more
dialogue options here if we had more use
cases and we can write for those wow so
truth be told I didn't feel like I was
running into that many obstacles it was
just yeah can we actually manage
mentally we we had systems in place so
like the like the way for scoping and
stuff it's like if you have the systems
that allow you to do those kinds of
things it's not it's not really that big
of a deal
um you know it's really more about like
you know are you gonna are you gonna
have the bandwidth to write it and then
the time to record it and then really
it's like yeah
yeah and and then and then and then
editing not the audio and implementing
it you know into the game you know
that's but but if you have all the
systems in place for that stuff to to
work it's or for any feature really it's
not that big of a deal we we had one big
scoping meeting
um we played through the block the block
and uh I can't I don't even remember
when this was a long time ago it feels
like now but
um
and we just it was like a come to Jesus
moment of like
you know all the directors uh me Alec my
my co uh Fridley and and just it was
like and Maddie or a lead producer and
they're they all kind of turned to me
and say like after a full week of
playing I mean like literally full week
a full week of just like playing like
like like I don't even know like 11 hour
days so great or maybe you know it was
crazy we were just only yeah over and
over and over yeah just notes notes
notes like this let's just get
everything let's just get all of the
notes and thoughts and stuff and at the
end of that
it was like okay
how like everyone in the room who has
more than what was it like 15 years or
10 years of game development experience
how long is the game we just or how much
more time do we need to ship the game we
just played you know and it was like uh
it was like like two years I don't know
it was something crazy and I was like no
so then so then we had you know we had
to like we had to figure out like okay
what do we do
yeah yeah my main thing was I don't I
don't want to go in and like hunt and
Peck and like you know I just let's just
find a thing that we can lift that's
going to just
you know be a knife lift and then Alec
and myself and you know and and like
we'll put our heads together and Julian
and and we'll like figure out how to and
with Eric and Mike we'll figure out how
to like like fix fix that list yeah we
like around it yeah
we cut like the whole mission at one
point which is pretty standard and yeah
I guess I've actually not spoken to
anybody on the show about that though
what does that look like like if you
have to cut a um plot Point what is the
actual process of making sure or you cut
like a side quest whatever it is what is
the process of making sure the game's
still cohesive just because yeah I try
to be informative on the show and I
don't think we've actually covered that
at any point if you have to cut a bunch
right so what do you do
yeah so I'll go ahead yeah well I know I
was going to say like I was just gonna
jump back to like Trover like Trover we
had to do that like three times
and it was insane and it would be these
massive lifts that also included a lot
of like a story
you know important stuff so so that one
was really complicated because I'd be
like oh [ __ ]
okay so we're cutting this whole section
and that happened three times a spread
out over the course of development again
pretty common and and
yeah yeah no definitely
um which is why
uh it was so kind of insane that we only
really had to do a crazy scoping Thing
Once on on high on life it was one
meeting one lift
and you know there was there's there was
stuff that you got in that mission we
just had to find a new place for it and
yeah
yeah a lot of it was just uh like mental
gymnastics trying to make sure we
weren't forgetting anything that was
introduced in that that we that we were
now going to miss and trying to find new
homes for it
um a lot of stuff was just like okay the
big example is uh there's like a suit
upgrade you were gonna get in this one
Mission and we had to find a cohesive
way to move that to another one and make
it feel natural without disrupting the
flow of that existing Mission
um and then you know on my end
tutorialize it yes or realize it and
like yeah and make it funny like make it
not feel wedged in like I think what we
ended up doing with it is actually
better than it started um which agreed
really nice but
uh you know overall like a lot of other
stuff was just like a list of ideas or
elements that were like narratively
introduced that we now had to just make
sure was included in dialogue and other
spots which is kind of like boring
bureaucratic writing where you're just
moving going through scripts right
yeah yeah and control effing everything
that's exactly what you dreamed of when
you became a writer
that's nice my favorite part document
God Bless yeah it's a lot um so because
of what kind of getting into the side of
things I'm curious because I've not
asked um how big was the team and how
long did it actually take to make High
online
oh man so it's about 50 plus people
right like just over 50. I think we're
we're close to 60 if not maybe slightly
over and um
you know we grew the studio for this
game you know Trover I think we were
like just under under 30. oh wow or
maybe some maybe maybe a little a little
over 30. I I I'm probably getting this
wrong I feel like I've heard lower than
that I heard like 50 yeah yeah
larger than it was
yes absolutely no I'm sort of thinking
like by The End by the end of drugs for
sure okay I want to say like it was
something like that but yeah no
certainly and the same was with this but
and then how many years like it was two
since I started and I came in like was
it October of 2020 is that right and I
think that's right that was at that
point like there was a vertical slice
playable that was in fairly rough shape
I think I can say but um a lot of like
concept art like pre-production stuff
still floating around and still in flux
that I helped come in and like uh
recodify as a cohesive story it was a
real video yeah we we yeah we we had we
had had prior to Alec I mean I I've been
living with this thing for you like
since you know 2016. well I did when I
was waiting in terms of like
yeah I mean like on paper right and like
2016 I had like it was a very different
game it was basically you know
it was a VR game it was gonna be uh
the the same kind of villain that was
introver and dogs getting kidnapped and
very different game but um but talking
guns were part of it
and and then we pivoted to make Trover
or I like that was my decision I was
like I really want this in VR like like
really badly and so we made that but but
that game was always in the back of my
head and then so whenever we shipped
Trover it was right like around then
that we started like working on high on
life like the the studio the team you
know everybody
um
yeah is that whoever came out I don't
even remember when did yeah okay okay so
yeah
yeah and then the last like the last
like two and a half
ish three years have been like
you know had like like I mean not crunch
but like you know we were full-time in
it you know we're full-time on this game
um
and it's a very ambitious game for for
an indie Studio a small Studio it's like
you know that we really yeah yeah
it is and it's and and like you said
earlier Alana like there's a lot of
stuff in here that you know maybe five
percent of people are gonna see or
whatever it is and you know we and we
had ideas where it's like oh my God we
should do this but it's like okay look
you know once you're deep in a fan it's
like and you realize you know you have a
good producer you've got a good team
that can kind of like corral everybody
and be like okay look this is the
reality of the situation we can't do any
more of these like high scope high
bandwidth things that like one percent
of players are gonna seeking but
um but we got a lot that I felt like we
had to hide from the team just a little
bit like kids people are still going to
see it but like just don't look if
you're working on something that yeah
exactly yeah that's amazing um you
touched on the talking guns I love the
talking guns I am such a big fan of that
both conceptually and in practice I
think it's such a good idea because you
are playing a video game and I feel like
so often video games can sense of the
storytelling like in a way that is very
a film and TV whereas talking guns
acting as companions like obsidian-esque
companions is just the coolest I'm a big
fan
um how just efficient right yeah it's
just it's just it's fun it's creative
and it gives you like a partnership with
something that would be on screen anyway
it just makes a lot of sense
um yeah how do you I guess this isn't
scope but it's more of like tonally how
do you decide how often they are
speaking or not like is there a
barometer for okay this one's talking
too much just gonna know why people okay
they should be quieter here
is that all a QA or like a play test
type thing
well I think first and foremost it's
just you know what gets the narrative
across like they need to speak in these
moments that's where we start and then
we also have like these just narrative
director Global lines that will play
kind of divorced from the story at any
time
um and those are the ones we really
tweaked like Eric and I would go through
uh there's our design director and we
would just go through it so with Andy
Kibler one of our other designers and
literally change the numbers on how
often lines would play when you shoot an
enemy or when you get hit or when you
fall into the toxic sludge or just when
the character wants to chat with you and
you know we would keep replaying it and
testing and seeing how it felt was it
too much we would disagree we would
agree it was really just like playing it
by ear
yeah and everyone's going to be
different I mean so like you know we
knew going into this concept that
there's going to be some Gamers that
this is just not for them like they they
don't want their guns talking to them
but I always felt like it like what you
said Alana like it was a natural
like like Dragon Age companions
masking with your weapon like it felt it
felt like a really great solid to tell
yeah and also great vehicles and
characters in which to tell a story that
it just it just felt so like cohesive
with what we were trying to do with like
the the higher Stakes of the story with
with the player and what they're doing
what's happening to the human race and
and these guns and their their backstory
and their role and all of that and um
and you know the enemy of my enemy is
my friend and you know you're partnering
with these guns to take down this really
bad drug cartel but
but like you know the challenge more so
because it was like you know look we
want to have unique dialogue all over
the place like we want we want the guns
to feel alive and my whole thing always
was like I really want them to feel
alive and unique
um if if we can
trick the players you know into that
like feeling that like the gun they're
holding is like has their their own
feelings and personality and is alive
then we've done our job
but um I think you nailed that but it
got
well thank you I'm glad to hear that
yeah yeah that's that's really amazing
to hear yeah I mean and then and then
having you know four different you know
main guns that we needed to write
dialogue for oh each gun has like when
it like when any gun talks we have to
write lines for the other three guns
talking as well and the player will only
ever hear one of those four each time
yeah so that was that was a real that
was a real scope like that was a beast
but but but that was you know we we knew
that from the get-go we were like okay
and we worked we worked around that to
make sure that we could do it you know
and not completely drown and like yeah
we talked about adding an extra gun like
we talked about the number of guns we
would have and how much extra work that
would add I think four was a really good
number for the main yeah and then and
then yeah yeah exactly and and you know
and then there is we even like this kind
of speaks to this topic like we even did
go ultimately and add an option in menu
that allows you to kind of you can you
can actually click a box that will make
the guns talk a little less or you know
like I think I think I think it's I
actually haven't tried it Alec have you
tried that feature yeah it's like those
numbers I was talking about where Eric
and I were sliding everything around it
just lowers them all and it doesn't
necessarily apply to the a story lines
like you still need to get crucial
information but it'll help if you don't
want to hear them it's a good idea yeah
if you don't want to hear the guns you
can do it like just in in general like
world you know like missions and stuff
you can you can hit that slider but I I
do feel
that we did such a good job with you
know the guns having different points of
view opinions like they're commenting on
different things there's backstory
there's there's just a lot of fun stuff
um and tons of jokes that the guns
deliver
um and people's characters if you don't
even asking like were they written with
character trees do they have like
um I don't know what the phrase for it
most Studios use but uh like a document
to make sure that their speeches is
consistent depending on who wrote it or
who delivered it like are they just
treated like any other character or was
there something slightly more
complicated
we were pretty loose with it in terms of
like those documents you're talking
about we had some stuff um but there
weren't like hard and fast rules we
leaned on the performers a lot too
um yeah remember Alec like it start like
like it was kind of like it started as
like okay we're gonna do these four guns
and we had it was more like archetypes
personality personality types it was
like okay so we you know we kind of knew
the Kenny gone and
we didn't really know his whole story
but we kind of knew like okay
personality-wise I think we got him
right away we knew he was like the more
level-headed reasonable gun he's
skeptical he's a little neurotic
you have like that that is a baseline is
really nice to have and then all the
other guns deviate from that a little
bit and we thought about in terms of how
you would want to interact with NPCs and
swapping guns for how you want to talk
to somebody would be the same as
swapping guns for how you want to
approach combat right so you have a more
aggressive gun you have a more sweet and
gentle gun and you have a wild card and
yeah the the root of how we would start
to write those personalities yeah once
we've found once we found those as our
four we were like okay this is this
feels really good because they all feel
really different you've got the hot head
you know which is Sweezy you've got the
sort of neurotic like
um
you know the first gun that kicks it all
off that's definitely got stuff you know
there's stuff there's there's that is
bad stuff to learn yeah there's there's
baggage and there's there's a reason why
he's really feels responsible to fix
things and then and then you have Gus
who's like this more chill kind of
gatlian
um played by JB Smoove and then you've
got the you've got creature who's a wild
card who's Tim Robinson and like he's
been experimenting on uh you know
biologically like like [ __ ] with and
so we just had a lot of fun with the
idea of like he's just he can just be
pure comedy like he's just like
and Tim Robinson could not have been a
better uh person for that character so
perfect
did you approach uh costing because it
sounds like the costume decisions
informed the characters in pot as well
oh big time they do it super early
I would say like Midway through was
probably the the most accurate
pinpoint like and then it was like we
like there was script
like a lot of script but then yeah Alec
after we cast Alec went back and and did
the pass I know for sure on JB stuff
right JB and creature got the biggest
like passes once we knew they were cast
um yeah
yeah and and and then you know we really
encouraged JB
uh to to just play around like like you
know we'd get the line of scripted and
then it was like let's get a bunch of
improv and so
you know we you know we that's that
stuff is my favorite stuff like hit JB's
improv stuff is like just gold pure gold
and so it could be nuts to hire him and
not let him improv like of all people
yeah
yeah no and he gets to say whatever he
wants yeah yeah and it was so fun to do
that and like you know it's just like we
just had to kind of we get the line we'd
sort of explain the scenario and then
he'd get it right away and then he'd do
a bunch of stuff and then we had to hire
actually two editors that were so their
sole job was just going through JB's um
wow records and making sure that we got
the really funny stuff in game
um and I I honestly bet you there's gold
that we haven't gotten that didn't make
sure we picture but there's just other
good goals yeah yeah yeah
so baby was a big challenge yet because
it was just so much improv it was one
well writing you're you're kind of
writing him in the edit Bay you know for
for half of it right well I remember an
early edit pass came back with a lot of
Alliance more as scripted and we were
like actually let's try to go off
bookcore with with what he did because
he always did the scripted line but he
had so much funny improv too yeah that
that was a moment where that was where
we kind of that I remember it was
freaking out because it was it was
getting late and development or in
production and I was like oh [ __ ] like
we don't have we don't have the goods
like the really good stuff in and that's
when we hired like a couple folks to
come in and just just
exclusively work on it's probably a lot
of mining all of that stuff yeah how
many how many writers do you actually
have on the game
the number would be like
up to seven or eight I think I mean
everyone worked on it in varying ways
like I was there the whole time we had a
writer's room uh kind of early on in
production
um and that was like a brainstorm yeah
yeah like an older Canadians yeah yeah
we knew we knew like the we like I had
had the even way back when we were
pitching this like forever ago
God I I I don't know what year that was
but we were at GDC pitching to anyone
who would listen
um
and
you know I I had the overarching story
like I knew I knew like the big the big
picture you know
um
but yeah you had like a whole skeleton
already and all we really did was tweak
things to make them feel a little like
tighter or or change things around yeah
no I mean we it got just way more
fleshed out and way better like like I
had like the the broad Strokes like the
like right we filled it in with what you
know like the skeleton the bones I had
the bones and then and then you know we
we we had we spun up a room with really
awesome fun people and just
how long how many weeks was that like we
had like a ride it was a long time I
mean it was well into like the script
writing they did some passes on like the
early early scripts too um so it was
yeah
it was a man it went pretty far in and
then like most of basically the the
writing room was dissolved uh once we
kind of had the game like set up and
stand like standing front to end yeah
and we had too many ideas like we had
too many funny things to even get in
like you know I mean there's stuff I'm
so proud I'm so excited that we got in
it's so funny that came out of that room
um so many ideas but like you know like
you were asking about comedy and a lot
of this stuff was just like premises you
know or like like scenarios and that can
just be funny no matter what like you
know it's like we come up with these
really funny scenarios
that when presented in game are just
going to be funny and there's so many
different ways that a player can like
decide to engage like one example you
you probably have already a lot of
people have seen and you've probably
played it at this point yourself as like
the little kid in the slums like early
on and and that's Joe that's Joel Haver
doing the voice he he was in The
Writer's room as well and he's so
[ __ ] funny and he did a bunch of the
like interdimensional cable crazy stuff
on the TV with along with me and Alec
and um
the uh like that little kid is a great
moment a great example of just a funny
premise you know like okay that like so
in the writer's room we'd have these
like just this bucket of premises that
we wanted to do and then implementing
them it was like okay so what are all
the ways the player can
you know interact with this what are all
the jokes that will come from those
interactions
um yeah there's just a lot of that kind
of stuff that made it in and then each
interaction kind of like uh when you
when you're building like a sitcom pitch
or something you need this thing to be
able to run for a long time but instead
of running for longevity we're running
for like eight different modes of attack
like all the different ways the player
might approach this joke they all need
to work and be funny in their own way it
kind of sounds like a nightmare possible
I asked about how many writers you have
it's like you'd have to hire pretty well
for it but did you work with anybody who
was like precious about things being cut
in favor of an act as improv or anything
like that
no no no it was it was it was mostly I
mean I hope the writer's room wrapped
uh it was it was mainly like you Alec
and and Julian Julian I want to say and
and and then I don't know like who like
in terms of like actually like that's
kind of
yeah from that point on we were just
sort of sort of polishing and making
sure things were like
I don't know just just coming together
in the right way it was less idea like
ideation at that point and more just
execution
and also also what's great is like we we
we we're very
um in sync comedically like like even
during like records like I would have a
note like a direction note for the actor
and Alec would literally say it in a
different way in his own way you know
and I'm like oh [ __ ] yep okay he knows
exactly he's thinking the same [ __ ] so
it like and then and then it's always
the best idea the funniest idea is what
goes on it doesn't matter who it came
from uh there's no like I don't like to
work in in environments where people get
weird about
you know their little thing getting you
know like it it can't be that way it's
got to be like especially in video games
you can't you have to let it go
yeah I think a lot of the comedians too
had not worked in games before
necessarily so this is kind of like a
new experience for them to a degree so
they they were also like super
interested in the process this was like
right sort of a learning experience for
them to be able to see the different
builds of the game and how it was coming
together
and also not precious like all the folks
we had are and the people I like to work
with in general are the kind that you
know they've got a ton of ideas and if
they don't care like if if one of if an
idea that they pitched that was that was
great doesn't make it in there's not
going to be any like that doesn't matter
like that's not no they're so used to
that like process yeah yeah that's what
you want I mean you know because stuff
there's a lot of great stuff that didn't
make it in just because of like scope
and budget and that we are a small
Studio I mean you know I keep saying if
we had another gear like holy [ __ ] um
but then it never runs but I think off
to the next thing yeah no yeah just one
more
I know that's exactly yeah that's
literally what I was about to say it's
like we I'm glad we I'm glad we you know
buttoned it down and I feel really happy
with with what we what we what we've got
here
um and if it you know we're just really
excited to to keep doing more in this in
this IP in this universe you know it's
very unique if it does well what you're
doing as well like there aren't a lot of
games that that uh play like this I
think like the closest I can think up to
the tutorial was that it made me think
of uh Far Cry blood dragon if either of
you played that oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah funny like sense of humor that not
a lot of AAA has it's super fun
um so I thought it was really fun oh
yeah sorry no no go ahead I can follow
up with this question
sure yeah I was gonna say that's that
was one of my favorite parts to write
because it has a different tone than the
rest of the game like it can just be
full-on satire at that point whereas the
rest of it is a little more grounded
protagonist is I'm such a fan of that
thank you yeah yeah that was so much fun
to record too because it was just like
like that that one was like there was a
lot of room to play there like you know
and and just that that silly like like
you know 90s PC very funny you know I
want to do more yeah yeah yeah it was
and just the like of it is that he's the
divorce attorney
it's like why is he like there's so many
questions you're like why is your
divorce attorney the guy who's like your
your metal Metal Gear Solid like like
voice in your ear you're my favorite
client and I was like can you imagine a
divorce attorney
incredible yeah yeah I love you you're
so cool you're so cool but it's just
like that was so much fun to record that
that was like that was like like the
game is the game like with Trover it was
like eight like 70 improv 30 scripted
something like that and this game is
split so this game's like way more
scripted just because you know we really
wanted to sell the story and make it
feel like the stakes were real and the
characters had arcs and and not you know
and like really like take it seriously
but then there still is that 30 of like
improv and and that opening has a lot
and then there's just moments of really
fun like one of my favorite moments
actually Alec does the voice of pseudo
the little in in suit um advisor guy on
the Bounty and there's a early in game
there's a funny moment when he's talking
about
um uh how to sprint like you know like
oh by the way you can Sprint and then
and he's like I would tell you what
button it is but I have no [ __ ] idea
what console or computer you're playing
on any and it's like you break he breaks
character and it's like we we still had
like though we still have a lot of those
moments all kind of sprinkled throughout
like the fourth wall breaking the kind
of like game developer or like a joke
because if you do it too much I feel
like it loses its luster but we right I
think we hit the right balance
yeah they're far and few between but
they're but they're they're just great
like little hardcore gamer jokes like
like if you're if you're if you're in
that world and you know play a lot of
games and or make games they're they're
really fun little jokes I love them
definitely yeah so I because I feel like
the tone of the game is very consistent
or at least that's the way that it comes
across I did want to ask how do you go
about hiring people at squunch like how
do you go about hiring writers are you
asking them what shows they watch or for
some of their favorite comedy when the
in the interview process what kind of
writing samples do you take like it's a
very
um it feels like a very different Focus
than a lot of other game studios so how
do you approach building the team
well from the writing perspective like
we had we had um Zach Gorman on in the
early days
um working with me
he was great like
um and then
and then we did like uh because we need
we needed we needed to fill that uh Alex
position we needed that role like that
was super important for this game
um and
we did testing like we basically just
did did and we've done it before and
Rick and Morty like in early season or
I'm gonna say maybe season
for we did it in season four we did we
did testing so it's not a big test it's
small it's just like um you know write a
scene uh like for Trover you know like
we had a Trover scene and then we had a
couple of like premises uh you know like
a couple of page a couple pages right
and and then any writing samples that
that the writers might have and then
um those came into the studio we got a
bunch of them
and then uh after I want to say Mikey
Eric Fridley a handful of people went
through them like the best ones were
then given to me I think I I want to say
I got like 20 or something it was a lot
um
and Alex was like my like by by far my
favorite it was it was like by by a
pretty long margin there there were some
good there was some good people in there
but but Alec just was do like like the
the level of creativity the ideas
I was like oh my God I want to make I
want to make this I want to do this I
want to actually make this thing I want
to make this moment you know like he
wrote a really fun Trover scenario that
was just so
so
um
clearly
like illustrating his understanding of
game and I'm trying to remember you know
it was like yeah
it was like a dark Trover remember yeah
yeah it was like a riff on Dark Link and
then you could it was this this other
dark we should find it and dig it up it
honestly I was like I I would I wanted
to make it I was like dude this is
exactly the kind of stuff that I want to
make and and he wrote it in a way that
that showed he understands games like he
he knows like whether he has written for
games or not I knew from his test that
he plays a [ __ ] ton of games and
understands game design and how to write
for games so
um I just I always say that like you
know we rolled it we rolled a 20 with
Alec like in terms of like getting
somebody on the team that that just
really fits in and everyone loves and I
was so nice thank you
I I I've told him this so many times
where I'm like I'm so grateful for you
like yeah I mean you know I I don't
maybe I don't do it enough but I
definitely yeah I was like I'm glad this
is a very but yeah no like we we really
really uh you know got lucky because
that is that could be one of the hardest
that is actually like especially if
you're doing because I feel the same way
it's a unicorn to find like I don't know
it's it's one thing to find somebody
who's like a funny writer but then a
funny writer who's writing to the same
tone and sense of humor that you're
looking for there's yeah it's just what
I always think is like
if you find someone who matches that
sensibility like write their name down
keep them in the back pocket like keep
an eye on what they're working on and
when they're available because they're
so valuable yeah and I mean Joel Haver
is somebody though he's kind of going
back to yeah Joel is you know if if
animations if anyone's listening if
anyone can hear me right now hello can
you hear me uh testing no but uh yeah
check out Joel's uh YouTube channel uh
did the viral like the the rotoscope
animation with um like fantasy
characters like ripping on Skyrim type
games I've definitely seen that yeah he
does a bunch of voices in the game too
he's so funny cool he's the little kid
he's the little kids
slumsley he's he it's so funny he's so
many voices in like the first like 20 30
minutes of game you know it's hilarious
he was a really reality player for us we
just keep bringing him in yeah and he he
brought a lot of really fun ideas and
just yeah he was he was a he's one of
those folks that like just fits right in
and
um
you know but but he works he works more
like
uh improv you know like less script yeah
and more like like Concepts and get get
him in front of a mic you know and like
they would send us like an audio
recordings instead of like written stuff
because he's like I I wow
that's actually very yeah but yeah and I
I mean I'm I'm a big like I'm a big
believer in like encouraging and
allowing people to work the way in the
way that yes exactly it gets the best
I think so too but I don't I I'm I'm
trying to push it in other areas of the
things that I'm doing and I I really
believe that is how the best stuff gets
made is you remove all of the math and
bureaucracy and just let let the if you
believe in somebody and you know they're
funny let them just create the thing the
way that is the most natural to them and
you're gonna get the best results that
way
um
and you know so yeah and Joel kind of
plugged right into our group perfectly
because he does that same kind of like
stupid interdimensional cable you know
style free association improv nonsense
that that that Alec is good at that I'm
good at um yeah Joel do a bunch of the
the TV sketches too like a lot of those
were just him in a booth with no prep
just improving um and I'd say like 15 of
those sketches are just him doing that
and they're all great that's so funny
yeah we ah man we have we have we have
one thing that the ice cream oh man like
it's still in the game yeah it's just I
know but we need to morph it a bit Yeah
so so it was it was if anyone knows Joel
like his buddy Trent is in a lot of his
stuff and Trent is incredible they're
they're just the best I love those guys
so much but anyway
we yeah there were a couple of aliens
and it was it was Joel and Trent and it
was so good and we had to like we had to
we had to figure it was for technical
reasons it came down to the way we
recorded the audio they were both yeah
like and they were finished
I am going to I am going to
I'm going to like in the game of Game of
the Year Edition or whatever the [ __ ]
it's called the director like down I'm
we're gonna [ __ ] just put the time in
to get that in exactly the way it was
recorded I don't care I want to be like
a podcast or something
no we'll just we'll just we'll just
we'll just update the game I'll George
Lucas said I'll just get it in there
it's like like this was supposed to I
guess that's not George it's a good
thing we have we have a good version of
it in the game it's just different
well what it is is it's an actual it's
an interaction with an NPC that has like
callbacks and like you know it's it's
really good and and I just I want to
figure out eventually how we can get it
exactly how we originally imagined with
Trent in there but that's awesome yeah
yeah yeah so it sounds like you hired a
lot of good people
you were taught you had probably some
luck that's part of the hiring process
right
um what were some things about working
on high on life that were extremely
difficult or the hardest parts of making
the game
unexpected challenges well well real
quick before before that I just want to
say also I I don't want to I don't wanna
I wanna make make it really clear that
like Eric and Mikey
um and like all all the all the
directors like were also like heavily
involved in the writing and uh big time
yeah conceptual yeah like so it wasn't
just like
yeah Mikey came in with like entire
backstories for planets and stuff like
that and that all ended up in the game
um yeah and Eric had these amazing
design ideas and like entire level ideas
that we would then figure out how do we
write this how do we make this work yeah
so it's different than TV where like
good TV is usually like the writers the
writers and the showrunner are the are
the leaders you know they're they're
like driving everything
um and then in games it's like you know
we're we are trying to take that
approach to a certain extent but we also
like Alex said like we want you you need
like these other things to come in and
and then that informs you know Story
character moments writing you know so
yeah like we we just have an incredible
I mean the team themselves like at any
level uh we're able to just pitch ideas
or try something out and I would say
like most of the time when they threw
something at the wall it's stuck um or
we just had to change it a tiny bit to
make it fit in with the grander vision
but like yeah people felt very enabled I
think I don't want to speak for everyone
yeah yeah yeah I mean yeah like like for
sure oh my God yeah like and we have
such a great team where everyone's sort
of on the same page comedically and like
they really believe in the content and
so good ideas were coming from all over
the place like
um we did like we specifically did uh
warp base jams which like in the game
you can collect uh warp crystals to
unlock these uh narrative jokes that you
can and teleport into the game uh and
you know those were like kind of each of
those was like a blue sky like we can
come up with any idea we want you're
you're warping in any coordinates in the
entire galaxy so any alien could show up
any setting and so we would literally do
jams where the team could just come up
with their own ideas and build out
little prototypes for each warp base and
every workbase that made it into the
game started as one of those jams yeah
yeah and we God we had so many uh we we
wanted to do so many more of those but
yeah again it was like it falls it's all
just side you know it wasn't like a it
wasn't the a story or the the golden
path so we you know it's obvious
obviously a place for cuts but um but
yeah the warp based mechanic is God that
is such a like I I sometimes
yeah yeah I was so damn excited about
that that whole thing
biggest challenges the hardest things
about about
um making the more unexpected challenges
things that were surprisingly difficult
ah I mean on my end I think uh this the
size of the game I definitely
underestimated just how many lines of
dialogue we would need and how many
different use cases
uh Pages it's at least a thousand and
that includes like the global Lions um
but
it's also yeah it's strange because like
we would do we would format it like uh
we just came with our own process for it
but we for when the guns were talking
it's dual dialogue and it's only one of
those four lines so like we'd write the
Kenny Gus we use the increature line and
then everyone working on the game knew
that only one of those four would play
and it would be whichever gun was out so
the the length of them is also weird
because some lines are stacked
um
yeah it's a lot it's a lot
um there were technical challenges you
know like there were things we that we
wanted to do that um
we just couldn't quite figure out
how to do them
um basically and also they weren't like
the most important thing you know it was
it would just be like little polished
little flourishes little cool things
that um
that we just ultimately like
it it it it it it didn't make sense to
waste
time trying to figure them out when
there were so much more important like
things that we we needed to work on but
official
um but yeah I'm trying to think of other
like channels you guys did a really good
job of scoping in a way that like I feel
like sometimes only Indie Studios can
it's really surprising to hear you're
like well you know we just kind of
talked about it and realized it didn't
fit like
um yeah but he he's great and you know
we you know it was like I'm I'm always
like my whole thing is like I I need
like a day or two to kind of just like
like like come to terms with a big cut
you know and then and then I'm good and
then everyone made the game better in my
opinion pacing wise like I think
ultimately they were the right choices
yeah and and but yeah it's like you know
there's some stuff that it's like ah
[ __ ] really damn okay and then you try
to you try to you try to figure out what
what is this it's always the future
somewhere else yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and that's yeah it's like it's
like well maybe we can maybe this joke
or this thing oh there's entire bits we
when we lifted we cut a mission we we
ended up like pulling some elements of
it back into another mission and things
were on like ice for a while and then
we're like oh [ __ ] this would actually
slot right back into the this this empty
part of the mission here so you would
always just save things
um and sometimes if we could yeah yeah
the best character get cut like a a year
and a half ago I'm still like can I get
it in something else oh my God
I mean same we we same same yeah and and
we're yeah we want to do you know we
want to do more with this world and so
who knows but
yeah it happens
um Before I Let You Go Justin I did want
to ask you a question because you
touched on it um the differences between
writing for a video game versus writing
for TV I've had people who've come from
theater backgrounds on this show before
but not from TV what what do you think
are some of the biggest differences
uh I mean well like linear content is
more I mean you got to really bring it
you know it's
it's it's it's passive for the um
for the audience so that they're they're
they're they're just sitting and
watching and if the story isn't I mean
you you have to really bring it with the
story The pacing the character the the
emotional core arcs all that stuff not
to say that you don't with a video game
if you want it to really like sing but
um but with TV you don't have
this sort of like
Foundation of good gameplay that you can
kind of lean on a little bit at least
psychologically like for me like like
it's like okay I'm gonna I'm gonna make
I'm gonna do an episode of TV okay the
stakes are pretty high it's got to be
[ __ ] good it's Gotta like we gotta
break a really good story we've got a
we've got a you know it's it's got to be
paced really well it's got to feel good
the characters gonna be funny blah blah
blah all that stuff
um and it can be
I mean as long as it's fun usually it's
fine but um
but it can be it can be trickier uh with
because you don't have that like okay so
with video games there's something
really really freeing in the sense that
um if the game plays really good and
feels really good
then
you know the writing
I don't know like there's less weight I
guess to it yeah we can lean on the
other departments a little bit like if
this part's not going to be as funny we
can just hope that the gameplay in the
Arts gonna carry it and vice versa but
but even even even more importantly it
it's a psychological weight that gets
lifted which ultimately results in like
a better like like things get better in
a weird way they're in a different
direction but it's like it's like you're
like okay well we let's do this and you
would never do quote this whatever this
is on a TV show because it just wouldn't
it would wait you'd be wasting people's
time you know you'd be like but let's
but you could do it in a game because
it's opt-in like the pla like a player
may want that and they will experience
it and go as deep as they want as deep
as as we've been able to make it and
then other players that don't want it
can just keep moving and it's like
I don't know it's so much more
um
I guess just psychologically free and
and fun and like well a lot of you know
I mean if the player does something
that's optional it's because they wanted
to do it if they stick with it it's
because they want to do it if it's a TV
show yeah you got 22 minutes they have
to watch the whole thing that's kind of
empowering right like they're opting
into the comedy too rather than just
absolving it yeah yeah and and you know
I you know it was important that we told
a really cohesive like grounded
narrative yeah like you know over the
course of the game that had you know
sort of this movie style beginning
middle end blah blah and emotional arcs
and all that stuff but
so we you know we that all of the kind
of core like ideation it was somewhat
similar but once you once you get past
that and you get in you know it's like
yeah there's there's something about
there's something about the fact that if
you know when the game feels really good
and it's fun to play and you're just
enjoying it
it just takes all this pressure off of
you from the writing side which then
frees your brain up to just be able to
have fun and not be like worried or
second guessing or and ultimately that's
when the best stuff gets made is when
I'm for sure for me anyways when I'm
like feeling that that sense of like
you know freedom and safeness or like
like I don't know you feel safe kind of
yeah yeah just fun and safe and and it's
like like you know it is a little bit of
what Alex said it's like oh this joke is
like here's a here's a joke that may not
hit but like it's happening during this
awesome shootout that
you know is is really fun gameplay and
there's so much like player story and
the way players want to play and how
they're going to play and
um that you get to kind of lean on and
be like well there's that though like so
if this joke sucks there's that you know
like I don't know there's some combat
man
look at this pretty Skybox
amazing yeah no but I mean we we
obviously want the game too I mean we we
we win it's always funny I promise no I
don't know I mean we we just had like
like I think the key to to stuff the
stuff that I've made that I love the
most is the stuff that I've I had fun
making
where I was laughing I was excited
um and
tend to honestly not to think about
where we are now we're like oh my God
it's in the world people are seeing it
reviews are coming in
um I don't think about that stuff while
we're making I I just think about like
how cool oh my God what about this oh my
God you know it's like really exciting
like when we came up with a warp base
idea that was just like so insanely
exciting it's like holy [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] amazing I guess it's like a
bunch of kids playing with toys
yeah like for really we pitched the idea
of uh what if you could watch a whole
movie in the game and then we just hit
the producers up like what would the
reality of this be and then that dumb
idea just became as committed bit that
we included in it we followed yeah I
reached out to the red letter media guys
and I was like like what what are some
like companies you think we should talk
to about licensing movies and they they
connected us with vinegar syndrome and
that we you [ __ ] life in four movies
four full-length movies are in this game
and it's like what like why like it was
it was there's no you know what I mean
it's like like who I was watching a
streamer earlier today yeah like someone
just is this the whole [ __ ] movie
like I love that reaction because that's
the idea
like the original the original concept
you know like oh man I'll just say it
it's like this is another scope thing
that like we had to we just had to we
did being a small team being an indie
team being being such an ambitious game
with so much going on but like the
original concept was those those movies
were going to play on the TV and we were
going to have Gene and Lizzy basically
be the like little mst3k like jokesters
you know just like riffin and a very
light version of that they do still say
Lions yeah yeah they do
yeah we had to really yeah we had to
really scope that back
um because you know it was actually very
challenging to get the movies to play in
the gameplay
yeah yeah it was like I was privy to a
bunch of slack conversations people
trying to figure it out and make sure
they're running properly and subtitles
were feeling too confusing yeah I I was
also kind of surprised that it was
difficult but I get it it was it was it
was a problem that that I think was
would have been solvable and achievable
but we just didn't have the time and
there was way more higher priority like
important things so but but but but that
was the that was the initial intent
intent was like you know to really keep
Gene and Lizzy alive if you want to hang
out and watch a movie with them and then
they're just talking like literally
moment to moment like mst3k like we were
gonna literally write the jokes the same
way that those guys do and
um we do have the the theater there's
there is one oh yeah should we spoil it
oh I don't know okay yeah yeah there's a
great call never mind
there's a well there is a the warp bases
are really fun bonus content
um and there's one that's really awesome
that you
yeah this is really cool there's a
really cool Warface that at least I
think it's [ __ ] incredible and I
can't believe we we've noticed before
yeah our team also did a great job
setting it up it's it's a very funny bit
well I guess yeah I encourage everybody
to check it out at home yeah yeah just
just just so this makes sense like the
work the way it works is like you get a
device in the game that you can actually
warp in boy alex you kind of said it
earlier you're like working in like
chunks yeah from
anywhere in the cosmos and it's just
random [ __ ] but um yeah there's there's
one that's a really really really well
they're all really funny but
yeah I wanted to do so many more of
those but it's very cool that you both
talk about this with such enthusiasm
like a lot of people have launched it
are like tired but you both just seem
like a very excited about what you made
and I think that's very tired trust me
hey we're tired we're tired I just moved
this weekend too my brain's like all
over the place oh boy yeah the the whole
team is is actually
surprisingly like just ready to go like
let's let's you know we want to do more
let's do more you know like it's it's
pretty yeah it's really cool I'm I I'm
I'm kind of yeah I love it I'm I'm
really proud of this thing and
um
you know yeah it's funny like who who
was someone's just asking me like
why mature why'd you why did you do
mature you could you could have made a
you could have made so much more money
if this was a T T for teen
and I I don't know I never even I never
even considered it it was always like no
like literally all of us more money
working in like children's TV video game
production I'm aware that if I wanted to
write kids mobile games I would be
making more money I don't want to do
that oh man yeah yeah that's kind of
that's kind of hold on I might want to
do that yeah wait a minute you mean
money
uh in exchange for not having fun yeah
no our next game will be edutainment
yeah edutainment
teaches typing that's actually not bad I
actually I actually kind of think maybe
you should do that that's a pretty good
idea well it looks like accounting like
like it's just you know if we did it it
would just devolve into chaos whatever
whatever it would be make it happen get
the people what they want
thank you so much for joining me to both
of you um Alec where are you where can
people find you and is there anything
else that you wanted to share
uh just this game get this game uh you
can find me on Twitter at Alec Robbins
uh that's probably the best place until
Twitter explodes but yeah uh Justin how
about you
oh uh I don't you can't really find me I
mean I'm I'm on Instagram you know a
little bit uh I don't post a lot I kind
of my relationship with social media is
sort of almost it's it's it's it's it's
atrophying more and more and more so
yeah no no I yeah
it's made it's made things better
actually it's made life better
um but um
but yeah so I guess I don't know well
just to remind everybody uh what
platforms is the game available on where
can they grab the video game Steam you
can get it on Steam you can get it on
epic game store if you're a PC
person uh it's also on Xbox uh all Xbox
One Xbox series s Xbox x and Freon yes
oh yeah and if you have Game Pass you
can just play it and and we're excited
about that because we think you know
like so many people like we we really
believe in this game we know we made
something really amazing and
Game Pass is a cool thing because I
think a lot of people that would have
otherwise not played it aren't going to
play it and I think I think we're going
to win a lot of people over and
that's our big that's our that's our
hope is like you know people play it and
talk about it and I do actually think
when you play this if you were on the
fence when you actually play it I feel
like it wins people over very fast I
mean I've seen tweets this morning of
people being like Oh my God the opening
to this game is incredible like I'm in
for a good time I've seen so many and
yeah the from the very beginning I think
it's very funny and sets a tone really
well you guys did a great job I'm a big
fan I think it's all thank you
appreciate it thank you yeah and then
just like the metroidvania like like the
actual game it's like such a game that I
that's like I want a game like this
right now so bad so oh I agree the game
itself is also fun to play which is kind
of fun also because it's not necessarily
necessary
like you could have just made some funny
Walking similar
yeah no I want it I want it's good to
know for next time okay
what the hell are we doing no but no but
like yeah I really I really wanted
something that that yeah like I I just
want more I want more games like like
this like not necessarily like super
comedy but just I really love the um the
Bioshock or the like
Metroid Prime yeah yeah where it's it's
like a first person like lock and key
mechanic upgraded new abilities like I I
just
that that is so that just gets me every
time and so um I'm in a jet pack I was
like oh my God that was such a big thing
I was like please begging there's one
point where we were gonna cut the jet
pack and I was like oh my God no there
was a lot of strife yeah oh my God yeah
it changes the level design so
drastically are you sure you want a jet
pack yeah no I was I was I was so
hell-bent on like I like that like that
was so important to me it was I think I
was like I want a jet pack so bad please
can I have a jet back please can I mean
that that is something that's really
hard to do like flying in video games is
really hard because then plays can go
wherever they want like that does
everything too accessible oh yeah that's
tough yes yeah
that's really tough yeah I mean we and
we and we you know but I I was saying it
from the beginning I was like I want a
[ __ ] jetpack please please please and
then I want it to be upgradable I want
you to be able to upgrade your fuel I
want you to upgrade your you know like
all like I wanna I wanna for players
that like it I want them to be able to
really like
be able to you know take the time to
Beef It Up and make it like the coolest
you know most fun jet pack they can get
but the ultimate chip and I just I just
like jet packs now listen did we do it
perfectly I don't know yes but I'll tell
you what if I you can expect to see more
jet-packed Shenanigans
it is upgradable yeah I'm gonna go
straight back to the pitch that the next
God of War is class plus new jet packs
please not enough games with jet packs
great closing note not enough games with
jet packs
um thank you both for joining me thank
you everybody for listening it was a
pleasure thanks for having us and check
out the game yeah thank you I had a
really fun time congratulations again to
the entire team on the launch
thank you thank you bye everybody